packing up again and feast of lasova has
nowhere to spend the night
she's moved around since her placement
on the homes for Ukraine scheme ended
she arrived in the UK nine months ago
with her beloved mini Yorkshire Terriers
Betsy Daisy Nora and Teddy they are
emotional support dogs for me they mean
everything they mean word for me because
I already lost everything because of
this war
as night falls outside a council
building in Berkshire help comes from
others who also have nowhere to go
the group forms an unusual procession as
anfisa who used to work in Ukraine
promoting cosmetics and her new friends
from bracknell's homeless Community make
their way to a nearby Church
tired and exhausted because all they're
just running calling searching so at
least I got a roof it's warm and I got a
meal yeah and my dog says me
several nights and fisa slept rough in a
tent in freezing conditions turning down
an offer of a hotel because her dogs
would have to go into Kennels
but whilst on fisa's situation is
unusual available data analyzed by Sky
News shows well over 4 000 Ukrainian
refugees and their families in the UK on
needing somewhere to live after their
placements on the homes for Ukraine
scheme ended the actual number could be
even higher
yeah very scared when we look for for
the new sources very scared and very not
we happen we we panic
at this support group in Reading
coordinated Tatiana Miller says the
refugees now want more Independence but
without a UK credit history or good
salaries renting is difficult
the main message is we need
compassionate landlords and we need
local authorities to work with State
agents to accommodate that so what
you're saying is some landlords don't
want ukrainians
some of them I'm not saying all
and Visa turned down offers of
accommodation from the council which she
says weren't suitable for her dogs now
staying temporarily with a friend of a
friend she's still looking for a place
to call home Lisa Holland Sky News